este es el aspecto que podrían tener
algunas ciudades del mundo si el
calentamiento global supere el grado y
medio celsius la cob 26 se anunció como
la última y mejor oportunidad para
evitar ese aumento de temperatura pero
en sus últimas horas el secretario
general de la onu dijo que aún quedaba
un largo camino por recorrer 10 launch
los anuncios realizados aquí en glasgow
son alentadores pero están lejos de ser
suficientes las promesas suenan vacías
cuando la industria de combustibles
fósiles siguen recibiendo billones de
dólares en subvenciones según el fm es
más airbag ayer la onu dice que su
último análisis muestra que el mundo
sigue en camino de un aumento de la
temperatura de 27 grados celsius el
calentamiento de un como un grado que se
ha producido hasta ahora ya está
magnificando los fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos como
inundaciones e incendios
la verdad es que la atmósfera no le
importan los compromisos sólo le importa
lo que ponemos en ella o dejamos de
poner stop putin en zúrich mientras las
negociaciones para llegar a un acuerdo
continúan el compromiso de acelerar la
eliminación del carbón y las
subvenciones a los combustibles fósiles
está generando polémica rusia y arabia
saudita están presionando mucho estaré
atenta al borrador para ver si han
tenido éxito países como irlanda francia
y dinamarca han prometido dejar de
conceder permisos de perforación pero
naciones productoras de petróleo y gas
no se han unido a la alianza otro gran
reto mundial es el apoyo financiero a
las naciones vulnerables para la
adaptación y mitigación de la crisis
climática las naciones más ricas se
comprometieron a aportar 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales para 2020
una cifra considerada como insuficiente
los estudios muestran que los daños
causados por el cambio climático podrían
superar los 500 mil millones de dólares
anuales para 2030